♪♪
Narrator: WITH AN ATMOSPHERE
OF SIMILAR DENSITY TO EARTH'S,
IT WAS BELIEVED TITAN MIGHT EVEN
HARBOR PRIMITIVE LIFE.
TO FLY PAST TITAN,
VOYAGER 1's GRAND TOUR
WOULD HAVE TO BE SACRIFICED.
TO VISIT THIS INTRIGUING MOON,
IT NEEDED TO BE PUT
ON A DIFFERENT PATH,
THROWING IT UP AT AN ANGLE,
OUT OF THE PLANE
OF THE SOLAR SYSTEM.
BEYOND TITAN,
THERE WOULD BE NO MORE
PLANETARY ENCOUNTERS
FOR VOYAGER 1.
THERE WAS ONE LAST, SPECIAL TASK
ITS MAKERS ASKED OF IT.
BECAUSE IT WAS HIGH
ABOVE THE SOLAR SYSTEM
RATHER IN ITS PLANE,
VOYAGER 1 HAD A VIEW
OF ALL THE PLANETS
THAT ITS TWIN COULD NEVER HAVE.
CARL SAGAN AND CAROLYN PORCO
BEGAN DISCUSSING AN IDEA.
VOYAGER WAS GONNA BE
IN A LOCATION
THAT NO OTHER SPACECRAFT
HAD BEEN BEFORE,
EQUIPPED WITH, YOU KNOW,
SOPHISTICATED INSTRUMENTATION
SO THAT IT COULD TURN AROUND
AND TAKE A PICTURE
OF ALL THE PLANETS
IN THE SOLAR SYSTEM,
AND I THOUGHT THAT THIS WOULD BE
A RIVETING COLLECTION OF IMAGES.
YOU KNOW, A FIRST.
♪♪
Narrator:
SO ON VALENTINE'S DAY, 1990,
13 YEARS AFTER LEAVING EARTH,
VOYAGER 1 WAS ASKED
TO TURN ITS CAMERAS BACK
TOWARDS THE PLANETS.
NOW, 3.7 BILLION MILES AWAY,
BY THE TIME
VOYAGER'S PITIFULLY WEAK SIGNAL
REACHED THE DISHES ON EARTH,
IT WAS JUST A MILLIONTH OF
A BILLIONTH OF A WATT OF POWER.
IT WAS THEN BOOSTED
AND SENT ON TO PASADENA,
WHERE THE IMAGE
WAS ASSEMBLED HERE
IN THE DEEP-SPACE CONTROL ROOM.
A UNIQUE FAMILY PORTRAIT --
THE ULTIMATE SNAPSHOT
OF OUR SOLAR SYSTEM.
HERE IS THE MOSAIC TAKEN...
Narrator: FOR CARL SAGAN,
THE SYMBOLIC VALUE
OF THE PHOTOGRAPH WAS A GIFT.
...THE PLANETS MOVE AROUND THE
SUN, AND IN ANY GIVEN MOMENT...
HE HELD A PRESS CONFERENCE TO
PUBLICIZE IT AROUND THE WORLD.
THE PORTRAIT OF THE PLANETS
HAS NOW BEEN TAKEN.
THIS LOOKS LIKE MORE THAN A DOT,
BUT IT IS, IN FACT,
LESS THAN A PIXEL.
IN THIS COLOR PICTURE, YOU CAN
SEE THAT IT IS SLIGHTLY BLUE,
AND THIS IS WHERE WE LIVE,
ON A BLUE DOT.
Narrator: WITH THIS FINAL
HISTORIC IMAGE CAPTURED,
AND NOTHING MORE TO PHOTOGRAPH,
VOYAGER 1's CAMERAS
WERE TURNED OFF TO SAVE POWER.
♪♪